I am an old redneck hillbilly guy I love
cars I love cars with big engines and
loud mufflers and trucks with big tires
I love vehicles I've got all kinds of
cars and vehicles in my life wonderful
ski boats and sea-doos and all kinds of
other stuff with motors in it
I like motors I like stuff like that I
get it you do too
we spend too much on this stuff and
sometimes it gets us into real trouble I
last two callers both at a car problem
they have both over purchased or on
their car $27,000 car with a $48,000
income a $32,000 car and a $10,000
motorcycle that's fifty two thousand
dollars tied up in vehicles with a
$60,000 income you will not prosper when
the total of stuff you have with motors
and wheels is over the value is over
half your annual income because
everything with a stinkin motor in it as
much as I love it goes down in value
they go down in value they're not an
investment I invested in a car then you
are a stupid but investor because that
your investment is gonna go down in
value why would you invest and something
goes down in value you consume a car and
that's fine I don't mind you having a
nice car I just don't want your nice car
to have you so the average vehicle is
70% of its value in the first four years
you own it so when you buy a new car and
you drive it off the lot when you hear
that sound and you go into the street go
across the curb and it goes blue glump
that was a ten thousand dollar sounds
you just heard Blount bloom
you just lost ten grand and you better
be able to absorb the blow the average
car sale in America right now is about
30 grand and they're gonna lose twenty
thousand of that thirty and four years
you're gonna turn thirty thousand into
ten thousand and scratch your head and
wonder why your kids college fund didn't
fund
you gonna turn thirty thousand into
twenty ten thousand and scratch your
head and wonder why you stay in debt
your whole life you're gonna turn thirty
thousand into ten thousand and wonder
why you're freaking broke that's why cuz
you got you bought stuff with wheels and
motors and it all goes down in value I
am NOT against you having a nice car I
don't drive drunk cars now but I used to
drive garbage I used to drive the stuff
that make a hoopty look good because I
drove like no one else so I could get
some money and once I got some money
then I can drive like no one else so
here's a plan drive something that only
you care about because it gets you from
here to there and quit trying to be sexy
based on your car oh my god how dumb are
you you know that that is not gonna make
you sexy a vehicle doesn't do it for you
baby I'm sorry so you're not cool based
on your car you're just stupid me too
I've done it too I bought all of it I
know what it looks like so drive like no
one else so that later you can drive
like no one else and a good rule of
thumb is to not have a total of vehicles
that equal more than half your annual
income because you're going to struggle
you're gonna stump your toe you're going
to stumble it's gonna be hard because
you're you're losing more money than
you're making is what it amounts to
and it just mathematically causes you to
walk with a limp it mathematically does
not allow you to sprint to be all that
you can be right it doesn't do that so
you know you make $40,000 a year
you don't need $20,000 for the cars
maximum of about $10,000 worth get you a
couple $5,000 cars get your income up
get yourself out of debt get your net
worth up and when you're an everyday
millionaire then go buy your new car but
you don't need to be buying a new car
until brand-new car until you're a
millionaire because you can't afford to
take the hit you're just gonna lose your
but on these things now I buy new cars
but I'm a mole
millionaire so I can afford to take the
loss and so I'm driving stuff that I
used to dream about driving some men
someday you know those dreams you have
well I'm driving that now but it's like
30 years into this deal so shut up
you know under the when we went broke a
guy loaned me a 1978 Cadillac with
400,000 actual miles on it the
predominant color on this thing was
bondo it was a bondo buggy it wasn't
even a certified hoopty it was just a
bondo buggy had a vinyl roof on the top
of it and when you drove it it filled up
with air looked like a parachute on top
this was white trash vehicle right here
and I'm driving this white trash
hillbilly vehicle I've been driving a
Jaguar before that that I sold two days
before it got repo'd because I was going
bankrupt this is how stupid I was so you
end anything stupid that I hadn't done
but I'm driving a hoop de Ville I drove
that car for ten years one three-month
period felt like ten years during that
three months but I'll tell you what I
did during that three months I saved up
a thousand dollars and bought a car gave
my buddy his nice loaner black back and
man $1,000 car was a sizable upgrade
from that 78 Cadillac cuz it just I mean
it was it was had to be one of the
ugliest vehicles I drove it over in the
nice into town and the cop started
following me profiling me it's like that
car is not supposed to be in this end of
town you know that's how bad this car
was so don't talk to me about whether
you have to have an airbag and you know
well you know just put your
mother-in-law over there that'll work I
mean come on seriously
golly I mean it's not safe
oh brother give me a break I mean you're
talking to a guy that grew up we slept
in the back window of the car when I was
growing up they would slam on the brakes
and we land on the floorboard my
generation my parents generation thought
seatbelts trapped you in the car and
would kill you in the wreck
no one or a seatbelt in those days now
I'm not saying that smart I'm not trying
to get much of you killed but we have
become a bunch of wusses in this country
and we overreact and over dramatize
everything in order to rationalize a
purchase that we can't afford so you
can't afford the car if you can't a pay
cash for it and B if the total of all
your vehicles equals more than half your
annual income and that includes your
$9,000 lawnmower by John Deere which
also goes down in value like a rock you
just bought the Bentley of lawn mowers
and so you're asking for it now I don't
mind you getting a John Deere I don't
mind you getting a Bentley but you pay
cash for it how less than half your
annual income and it's not brand new
unless you have a net worth of a million
dollars this is not something that
matters to me I'm not gonna be driving
your car I don't care what you do I'm
teaching you the math that works for you
to become wealthy and it doesn't include
conspicuous consumption with four wheels
conspicuous consumption is I buy stuff
so that other people think good of me I
want you to see me that's why I bought
that first Jaguar I thought it made me
look cool it didn't it didn't I was no
more cool in that Jaguar than I was in
that $400 hoop deville bondo buggy I was
still just Dave and you're still gonna
be just you no matter what you put the
key in and turn it doesn't make you a
good mommy it doesn't make you a good
husband it doesn't make you a good
whatever it doesn't make you an eligible
bachelor if you're so stupid that you
would date a boy or a girl based on the
car they drive you're not marriage
material who wants to have someone has a
relationship that's that's shallow I'm
not going out with a guy that doesn't
have a nice car well you're a princess I
need to stay away from I'm just
so seriously this is the stuff that goes
on the culture every day out there and
it's the messages that play in our
brains that have caused this country to
be the wealthiest country that the world
has ever known and yet most people while
making a pile of money have absolutely
none buying crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like you got to
stop it